[Music]
becoming the best
doesn't simply happen overnight it takes
hard work
and countless hours to reach the top of
any esport
sometimes failure is motivation but only
for the strongest of competitors
but what happens when you become the
best wait do you see this kid wait till
you see this kid
some grant they have to get on the point
with most people sinatra diving deep
so deep right now they can't even reset
three percent
left can anyone even touch this point he
was
the chosen one for the san francisco
shot to turn their entire
franchise around what happens once
you've accomplished everything
are you the best player in the world
um yeah what happens when the world's
best player decides to walk away at the
height of his career
sinatra is the overwatch superstar right
he
is from the other side of the pond i'm
from counter-strike but i've heard his
name
a lot look how slippery sinatra is here
that careful comes through
to keep himself alive somehow getting
the running head shot and just dodging
left and right
this guy's like mohammed ali right now
this guy is like
probably the best player in the world
right now in this game like honestly in
another game is crazy
it's just gonna be sinatra misses one
but gets the second that's a triple
oh before oh my goodness
and now the show stopper to get it and
he got something
oh my gosh i'm just gonna go out and say
sinatra is my favorite and to me i think
he's the best versatile player in the
game now they don't know
where sinatra is oh my ward
that was a shot sentinel have a star
[Music]
jay sinatra wan grew up in shoreline
washington with a love for competition
he played high school baseball but he
never saw a future in the sport so
he quit and with the launch of overwatch
in 2016 he decided to turn his focus to
esports instead
sinatra was already playing
counter-strike and overwatch regularly
but by the second season of competitive
overwatch
he reached rank 2 on the north american
server at only 16 years old
this caught the attention of many orgs
and he eventually dropped out of high
school entering his first professional
contract with selfless gaming with the
inaugural
season of the overwatch league on the
horizon sinatra eventually found himself
at the center of a bidding war between
the london spitfire and the san
francisco shock which ultimately
resulted in him
signing for the los angeles based team
yo what's up guys sinatra here just
wanna say that i'm super stoked to be
representing san francisco in the
overwatch league
we're stacked we're nutty let's go but
as excited as sinatra was about
competing
for the first part of his career he
found himself sitting on the sidelines
when i first got signed i was 17 years
old but it was like
a four month period where i had to wait
before i turn 18 i could play it
so i had to basically skip stage one and
two
however before he'd even played his
first official game
sinatra was already making headlines
specifically in september of 2017
when his salary was leaked revealing
that he was making triple the league's
minimum salary
a number that many felt was unjustified
that november sinatra was invited
to be part of team usa's world cup squad
where he tried to prove that he was
worth his 150k price tag
sinatra's continues to run wild has
another grab ready
this is why sinatra built ultimate so
quickly he's so deadly in atari
and now has what could be the cleanup
ground taunt united states leading the
way the victory
he's going to drop the graviton gets
willax and the united states they're
almost there
south korea they are out of time toby
gets picked off that is massive
now in some grand they have to get on
the point with most people sinatra
diving deep
so deep right now they can't even reset
three percent
left can anyone even touch this point
say will be he's
no doesn't get there the united states
takes back one unfortunately for sinatra
the team suffered a disappointing loss
to south korea but
he placed a lot of the blame on his own
shoulders
i expected to do really well against
korea but honestly i've never played a
korean before that so
i didn't know how they played and then i
just played way too aggressive and i
didn't adjust so i just did
really poorly so i'm pretty sure we lost
because i didn't do well
like i'm pretty sure that's why we lost
after finally turning 18
sinatra was able to make his debut for
the shock and despite the team's
disappointing results
there was some optimism surrounding his
arrival
you did see sinatra though play pretty
well in his debut you'd expect the shop
to just get better
that'll be the mayhem that come out
victorious today a lot of pressure to be
honest because everyone for the past
three months have been saying like oh
sinatra is going to like
carry this team make the biggest
difference but it's a team game in
in the end so to reverse the shocks
fortunes the team brought in
daehy crusty park as their new head
coach in may of 2018
and krusty's arrival marked a huge
turning point not only in sinatra's play
but in his life see sinatra had
developed a bit of a reputation for his
talks behavior in the past but krusty
helped him harness his occasionally out
of control competitive spirit
and redirect it into being a mature and
positive leader for the team
the shock came out of the gates swinging
in season 2 earning themselves their
first
ever playoff berth they fell short in
the finals of stage 1 though
losing 4-3 to the vancouver titans in a
hard-fought series
but the team didn't just stop there they
dominated in stage 2 on their way to a
28-0
map record and became the first ever
team to complete a golden stage
then they breezed to a rematch against
the titans in the final
the spark are going to be under a bit of
pressure god's been trying to burn true
hoping down make it so he won't have a
mech to even eat the crab with
another
there but he wasn't ready for the face
full of damage about gets served up
and the san francisco shot get rid of
that big threat now they can continue to
fight this out
absolutely perfect play from san
francisco to get over the line
all right using things flying a little
bit closer to the ground there's no oh
it doesn't work though
does it show over says remember me
they baited them into that so hard oh
god and now the shock this is going to
be a one-sided fight
fusion are the the defending finalists
of the 2018 season
they're an eight and five team but i
you know i don't know if anyone could
disrespect them this much destroying
them right now
taking 4v6 fights i mean it's such a
slaughter at the moment that's all we
can really say
no hesitation he just used it he's
already up to 40 again it's not enough
for san francisco to beat you they want
to demoralize you
ding running for his life that's what
he's trying to spread across the map and
he has to reveal himself to contest the
payload and he does so just for a brief
moment but no one else is there
it's over the san francisco shock
completes the golden stage and the shock
this is the team that was promised last
year by san francisco saying you know
we're going to pick up players that are
too young to play right away we're going
to train them
they're going to turn 18 they're going
to start playing and they're going to
win
and that is exactly what we're seeing
the shock had
finally achieved what they set out to do
and you could just see
how much it meant to sinatra i just
jumped up and started
yelling with my team and then i
literally started crying the first like
five seconds
but by stage four overwatch itself had
changed the 222 system forced
every team to play with two support
heroes two damage heroes and two tanks
off the back of their disappointing
stage three loss the shock
stormed back winning all seven of their
matches in stage four
and sinatra was named the season two mvp
i've grown a lot last season i was you
know a pretty
pretty toxic you know ego selfish kid um
but coming into this this season uh i i
gotta give it to my coaching staff
uh krusty junk bug 9k they really help
me um just grow as a player an
individual a teammate and a leader
um so i'm just really grateful for them
despite riding a personal high
sinatra's joy would be short-lived when
the shock crashed out of the
quarter-finals against the atlanta reign
but sinatra wasn't ready for their
season to end he and his teammates
wanted to show that they were still the
best team in the league
and after dominating each and every team
they faced in the losers bracket
the stage was set for the shock to face
off with the vancouver titans
in the grand finals and sinatra was
determined
to come out on top sinatra goes in early
look at the disruption in the back line
meteor strike he gets rid of the
supercharger
lucio is missing against himself another
one is far from done
they carry the twine under the upside
room and then san francisco
only a few seconds left solving sue is
removed from the face of the map but
architect it's time to get his hands
dirty
hacksaw throws a blizzard down but it's
not enough twilight
the last hope for the titan steps up he
is filmed
since he now gets to the point where
slime is already removed from the fight
the wrecking ball is down in january he
can't touch
he is walled off the door is shut down
sinatra had finally accomplished his
ultimate goal
he had won everything imaginable in the
overwatch league
but he wasn't done yet his performance
throughout 2019
earned him a place on usa's world cup
team once again
i say this every year but like korea but
i mean that's like the obvious one
but like especially now because they
have krusty and like architect troy
hogan
and i really want to be krusty dab it'll
just be funny
making fun of him and sinatra finally
got his revenge
after a 3-1 win against south korea the
u.s dismantled china 3-0 in the finals
and once again sinatra's performances
had earned him a claim
for the first time on behalf of the
fandom
who got the opportunity to pick who is
going to be
the first fan selected t-mobile
mvp cenotrol
sinatra had done it all the once toxic
teenager was now the
only player in overwatch's history to
win an overwatch league championship
and a world cup while earning the mvp
trophy in both competitions
now i have to ask you got the overwatch
league mvp
now i get the overwatch world cup mvp
are you the best player in the world
um yeah yes
but what sinatra did next didn't just
shock the overwatch community
it turned the entire esports world on
its head
this is espn esports i'm ardo o'cow
let's talk about the big news that
sinatra
the mvp the reigning world champion
and marquis player of overwatch league
has decided
he's leaving overwatch league entirely
he's leaving the san francisco shock and
nrg as an organization and will be
pursuing
a pro-valorant career joining sentinels
i was pretty nervous changing games
definitely had
thoughts of failure in my mind but the
worst thing is like regretting
not doing it so i just took the chance
on valor when sinatra announced his move
to valerian some observers were
skeptical about how he would match
up in such a vastly different title but
after joining the sentinels roster
sinatra hit the ground
running it's the final round as well so
you can all die to the bomb you don't
have to worry about weapons here but
sinatra says
worry about my ultimate there are two
random shots that will land
for back-to-back kills only mommy alive
he's got to go clutch in the 1v1
i cannot believe it i cannot believe it
this time doesn't work out as it gets
punished by a full sight push
here's the fleet tank this is gonna be
sinatra misses one but gets the second
that's a triple kill oh
you got four oh my goodness and now the
show stopper to get it and he got
something
oh my gosh
sentinels looked dominant throughout the
summer of 2020 winning the north america
ignition series
and sinatra's play received plenty of
praise
people memed about sinatra at first and
like we didn't have a full five so we
couldn't play
and uh like play and like develop a
tactical because we're trying outfits
but like this guy is like probably the
best player in the world right now in
this game like
honestly in another game it's crazy he's
ready to make it work either way
the 2v1 now pocket can he make it work
sinatra coming up with possible 4k
sentinels oh my god have a star
sinatra with the ace on map one
and here comes a counter rocket kapoor
who's trying to do it but shazam
shuts it down 13-8 sentinels are gonna
lock
up the final n a ignition series event
of the year
sinatra and his team had cemented
themselves as the best team in north
america after only
three months together but in september
of 2020
riot announced their first sponsored
event today we are announcing our next
step for ballarat esports
and the first tournament organized by
riot games
first strike this extended event will
provide the first opportunity for
players in north america
europe asia latin america and other
places around the world
to earn the title of champion in their
region
sentinels were one of the favorites to
win the entire event
but unfortunately on november 29th only
four days before first strike
sinatra's teammate and igl shazeb shazam
khan
shared some sad news in a tweet shazam
explained that his father had passed
away but despite his loss
shazam decided that he still wanted to
compete at the event
we just hope for his recovery we don't
really care about like the performance
that much
like obviously we want to win but like
his mental definitely matters the most
so we're just we're just praying for him
and
just trying to get through it together
um and obviously try to go out with a
bang you know
put our hearts in the matches stuff like
that so yeah
their first match was against faze clan
a team full of players who sinatra had
previously played with
and against in overwatch and all eyes
were on sinatra
so starting off with sinatra and i'm
just gonna go out and say it sinatra is
my favorite and to me i think he's the
best versatile player in the game
you catch up on reyes jack silva it
doesn't matter but it's not about his
versatility between the agents this is
versatility and play style the fact that
he's able to speed it up get in your
face we all saw that raise push
but also is sofa he's able to get intel
push in
very strategically and smart and secure
those 1v1 wins
and it just helps out the team so much
sentinels defeated faze with ease in a
swift 2-0 to earn themselves a spot
against the new look hundred thieves in
the semi-finals
dapper again the last one alive lone man
standing and he
falls to steal dicey nitro and hiko
all left up to keep the game alive and
it's just gonna be hiko now versus five
it looks impossible it is gonna be
impossible as sinatra hits his 3k
look slippery sinatra is here that
careful
to keep himself alive somehow headshot
and just dodging left and right
this guy's like mohammed ali right now
in the ring as he takes down hiko
that is so so crazy to see
dapper actually has result here if he
can get to it he's going to drop the
cage that oh they have no idea that he
goes here do they butt so
something's going to go down he could
defend they needed to kill hika they had
to find a way but this guy is going to
stay alive
and that's match point now for 100 fees
sentinels trying to regain composure in
the site it's going to be 100 thieves
taking the series and meeting tsm in the
first strike grand finals
sinatra and his team couldn't overcome
100 thieves
but they made top 4 at riot's first
major valerian tournament without two
full weeks of practice
but this wasn't enough for them they
wanted revenge and once the dust settled
around for a strike
they got their chance jbl's quantum cup
took place a week later and featured a
hundred thief sentinels rematch in the
semi-finals
they're gonna go in for this the hot
hands halfway no not gonna happen
sick finds one outside oh my goodness
now you got two players
400 thieves waiting in the wings to just
try and push this one outward
piko alone not gonna happen a flawless
round for sentinels
nitro gets a double but sick lands
himself a big kill
now it just leaves it up to nitro but
the hot hands
burns them gg sentinels take game one
sentinels lost game two meaning that
they would once again be playing hundred
thieves in a game three semi-final
but they had learned their lesson
sentinels chose to ban
bind which meant that map 3 would be
played on icebox
and this time they even the score
grenade forces the jet up into the op
shot here comes the rocket as
it's shazam and sinatra looking to close
this one down
yeah there's just no options nothing at
all as sick as gonna invest now they're
getting aggressive here on yellow and
that's gonna turn into a double shutting
down the hunters fury from hiko
and this is the round no no no no they
got to be paying attention they got to
be paying attention
he could shoot through the smoke he's
got to go through this one here then he
gets the kill no
he can and shazam is going to get it
instead it all boils down what can nitro
do he's been clutch before but it ain't
going to happen this time
and sentinels will win moving on here
at the jbl quantum cup sinatra and
sentinels had overcome the hurdle that
was 100 thieves
but they weren't done there in the
finals he got a shot at faze
along with some old overwatch teammates
what no why equip it
chat clip it send it to me on twitter oh
no but wait a minute though with that
double kill but they have to fly they
need to take this one out here
zombs can't do it oh it's gonna be
close and we're going to overtime two
seconds remaining
camera's not deep enough and they're not
gonna know in time oh
but he could stick it again he's gotta
go in there and he's gotta go and he's
gotta look at him he's gotta look at him
oh my god
zachary's heating up
shazam baits him into zombs perfectly he
was not
attempting to shoot his operator there
he was simply setting up his omen and
that's why i love sentinels so much
the cold peak around this corner and we
could be looking at it that's right
folks
gg sentinels back to their winning ways
as they walk away
with the jbl quantum cup trophy
for sentinels they were frustrated with
their performance and first strike they
knew they weren't playing at the top of
their level
they get the rematch they wanted against
100 thieves i felt like just winning
that match
they had the monkey off their back
valorant has been out for less than one
year
and sinatra is already considered one of
the best players in the game
now they don't know where sinatra is oh
my ward
in that was a shot he faked running away
with the weak combo with the last tag
and so he's gonna
backstab him oh wow
he is part of a rare breed of player who
have been able to compete
and win at the highest possible level in
multiple games
and with riot announcing their champions
tour in 2021
sinatra will have plenty of time to show
why he is one of the hardest working
competitors in esports
his desire to win and be the best
allowed him to conquer overwatch
and now he has a chance to conquer
valorant
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages